boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saucon we
are at the transformative technology
conference we are speaking with Oh fair
Leidner now hello hi LM co-founder of
half AI great to meet you to be here I'm
really excited to chat with you so even
before we get to everything that happy
face doing I want to know about you how
did who are you how did you even get
into the space so my name is Alfred
Leidner I am the co-founder and
president of amplify I am based in New
York or at home has been for me for the
past 20 years
hard to believe grew up in tel-aviv
moved to the US and for the past six
years with happy why prior to have I
spend a decade building a fairly large
casual gaming company so you know these
experiences that people spend too much
time on get addicted to and ultimately
leave them in a sense of pleasure but
not much more than that so we got a lot
of people addicted to playing our games
and I've done it for a decade and part
did another companies I've been an
entrepreneur for the past 15 years how I
got here is that following my experience
with a gaming company I had a strong
sense that we can do something better
with our expertise engage people through
digital devices we did it at scale over
60 million people in our gaming platform
back in the days so I got really
interested in kind of applying
principles of engagement habit formation
with technology and evidence-based
practice and try to help people live
better and now that's so interesting
that you did the transition from the
just games that were maybe less
beneficial for humanity in some ways or
beneficial in some ways you know they
are beneficial they are their strategy
and you learn teamwork and resource
management in some ways and some yeah
with some games they were educational I
would I wouldn't discount games
completely I think hold a great I love
games I'm a gamer by heart but I do
think that if you look at the
trains of games and how they're
ultimately trying to create highly
optimized have information like that are
basically kind of messing around with
your dopamine in various mechanics color
palette sounds level progression
mechanics we thought that this dosage
that games are designed for today
creating a negative impact on kids I see
it with my own kids yeah and there may
be something better that we could do
with that skill set to help people even
better yes
and now how did the transition come to
half how did how did you go I want to do
this now so we in 2010 we actually 2012
we started working on the idea and we
knew that we're looking for a place
where the engagement expertise in design
consumer centric design would have a lot
of impact living in New York you see the
demand all day long around you people
are working long hours the stressed
overworked a lot of folks on the street
unfortunately was emotional mental
health challenges and for us it was
never a question whether or not there's
demand out there product we just thought
that people needs different tools and
what they have today to be able to get
the support that they need technology
and mobile devices now allow us to put
incredible computing powers in the hands
of people and use this computing
computing power for good to do something
that help them live better so that's
kind of the idea we had an IT system
back-end that if we match evidence-based
practice that we get really interested
in beginning positive psychology
cognitive behavioral therapy mindfulness
if we take all of these evidence-based
interventions that has been sitting on
the kind of academia academic shelf for
years but not reaching the mass-market
if we take those and bring them with our
expertise and create engaging
experiences these stigmatized
experiences people would want to consume
them and they'll see the benefit so this
was a thesis it took us about
two and a half years to build the
product and optimize the experience we
from the get-go so that we got on
something if people want to use and want
is at the dosage it we felt that is more
reasonable to achieve the result and the
behavior changes we wanted
and from there you know we spend time
building a consumer offering at first
scale D two three and a half million
people and whoa
and wow what is what was the offering
those it was a freemium subscription you
could come in we would offer you a
variety of programs on the platform that
allows us to essentially on a global
basis today because our platform is
global screen very quickly understand
what brings it to the platform provide
you evidence-based programs on a wide
array of topics from preventative
well-being all the way to diagnosable
mental health conditions and really let
you do these programs and interventions
in design that is kind of its conscious
of your the amount of time that you have
your busy daily life how you like to
consume this essentially applied a lot
of the principle of designing good
consumer centric product but kind of
create something that also was
measurably delivering impact so that's
kind of the first phase of the progress
and then in mid 2016 we start getting
approached by a large organization and
large employers health plans and other
kind of population health management
organizations and they be said we have a
lot of people that might need this
product so fast forward today we're
working and tell us about the product
quick so happy fight calm when I go and
I get involved with your service I am
starting to do what so so on the product
on the end it's it's a product that's
available on the site apps native
vanilla the platform and essentially
would come in it would quickly screen
and entice you into one of four sixty
different emotional health programs that
are delivering highly interactive
evidence-based interventions to help you
improve your emotional health
interesting so then what are the what is
the
what are like how long does it take for
me to answer questions about Who I am
for you to get a good idea of these
metrics that that's a great question
because you know one of the challenges
is that you know
design-wise we all eager to get as much
data as we can but the engagement wise
we know that if we asked you too many
questions you're going to go away so we
have an assessment today that has nine
questions that give us very strong
indications of where you are and what
brings it to the some of them so some of
the interesting question is for example
you feel sometimes that you like it
aren't boring so we know that when
people are bored it's often a signal for
emotional health challenges fatigue also
same interesting the board question is
very interesting because if you're doing
something that you love every single day
there's no chance that you're bored and
so will fatigues another interesting one
as well it's because how hard are you
are you do you ever relax your body do
you ever meditate do you ever go to
nature do you ever have blissful time
with your friends and family
yes in some right there from it from a
the product design point of view I think
you lost many users because he asked too
many questions so we try to condense it
to a number of questions that would give
us a really strong signal for example
when I met not so much about asking them
those questions but more so just on a
point of just emotional health and
well-being yeah if you're if you're if
you're answering the questions to
fatigue and to boredom either you know
wherever you're answering those
questions and I'm curious are you doing
it like on a 1 to 10 scale or do you so
there's scales that helps us understand
and get the right signal where you are
another interesting question that we had
on this assessment is how socially
connected you are you know we do know
that one of the biggest health epidemic
nowadays is social isolation and an
addiction to
yeah social isolation yeah yeah but
social isolation essentially you know
people get the antidote by fake social
interaction but social isolation is a
major signal for depressive symptoms
health symptoms yeah so all of these
questions we put them on nine question
we optimized this assessment yes and
then we based on that will prescribe to
the program why there are F programs
we'll get you into the program and then
you start doing this interaction in
interactive interventions they all
evidence basic so six years three and a
half million people yeah that's on the
consumer side that's uncomfortable you
get it a high five
good job and then so quick question is
out of those out of the last six years
now how many people are you funneling
into the next those are those those
interviewed those interventions like
which interventions are the most popular
for the Center for the emotion site
you're working with so we have variety
of engines we over 3,000 different
intervention experiences if you will
anywhere from you know classic self
reflection journaling interventions
interventions that are involving light
gaming audio visual relaxation
experiences we measuring with sensors
objective stress level and then provide
you deep breathing exercises all the way
to classic CBT intervention and
cognitive accepting therapy and other
accepted clinical modalities unique way
about how we'll be delivering it is that
the principle is that it has to be
something that people would want to do
so it's got to be fun
it's got to be engaging it's got to be
distinct meet eyes it's got to be
readily available and personalizable
yeah and when you get all of these you
get really good engagement and people
use the product which is what we didn't
know when we started it was a very
interesting experiment Hey we put
interventions we digitize them and we
create fun experiences around them will
people use will it be effective will we
see the clinical outcomes and
the first part of our journey where
people were willing to pay and the
answer was yes so so cool ok so then so
then someone that is logging in it goes
through the process of answering the
questions they get they get aniseh you
get their assessment can they access
their assessment like how you rank them
in the different areas yes so the
process of self care for emotional
health goes through awareness right you
gotta be aware about your condition you
gotta be feeling comfortable to look at
the data and we've created an interface
that allows people to track how they're
doing great unlike product that would
kind of attack it a very negative
stigmatized way hey if you depressed
click here or you depress we have news
for you we have kind of distich meters
it and you know call the assessment
happiness score have enough score happen
if socially after I finish an
intervention how can you tell if I'm
happier do you do I retake the so the
clinical protocol you come on board with
measuring day two and then every other
week and we track their every other week
every other within a my taking at
different nine questions or same or the
clinical assessment is different than
the onboarding assessment yeah yeah and
then you're taking that and every other
week these are the same questions
clinical assessment is how many
questions is that well it depends on the
type of clinical assessment in more
clinical settings we'll work with health
plans you know we would use phq-9 got
two got seven these are very clinical
assessment tools in more kind of
environment that we want to do
population health
so we want to engage many people and by
de stigmatizing the whole process which
is Happiness score happiness score is a
clinically validated assessment highly
correlated with speech to nine and in
fact it has been accepted by the health
plan as a clinical tool that they are
using now at this this signifies
engagement clinical assessment tool that
they're using and then what what does
the this is this one when I'm when I'm
doing the inner vet
do I do an intervention and then do I
depends on the intervention probably if
I do it again later or not
so we personalize the experience for you
based on what we know works and kind of
protocols that are working we
personalize it so you know if you come
in and we for example putting in front
of intervention that is using journaling
but guess what you didn't like
journaling there is no point in putting
this intervention in front of you that's
exactly how we would send you away if
you are coming in and we ask you to
meditate but you're not a meditator we
lost you right there so we would kind of
personalize the tools on the journey and
then around this kind of experience you
know we have community experience we
have psycho-educational you know we kind
of took a lot of the elements that make
consumer product successful with
behaviors that we know people like so
people like Pinterest lots of people
kind of pin happy moments and things
that they develop emotional attachment
let's look at support group so we know
that when it comes to feeling stronger
tied to a community you get support you
know they wait water model the analog
model can we bring it online and support
people that want to use get some support
and encouragement from a non-judgmental
environment and people that go through
different situations like theirs or
other but they're all dealing with
something does half of I also helped
bring the communities of people in the
local environments together that are
working on
so not at this point we are a self-care
technology we went out to solve the you
know the enormous challenge of access
convenience yeah you want to kind of you
know we have one in five people dealing
with mental health conditions here in
markets other than the u.s. there are
markets where this simply tremendous
challenge in in getting the right
resources you know
the only way in our mind to solve it is
by good self-care solution and
technology that can is easily accessible
over the internet just like that
is is how much is the cost of the
software so it depends where we're
selling it right so we we're selling on
the consumer side you know roughly
speaking hundred thirty dollars a year
subscription which if you compare us if
you compare it to any other modality of
care if you look at what it cost see if
you go to your therapy or rather this is
very affordable way to the same price is
a beer a month or Spotify you know
there's yeah I used to like the analogy
of you know and coffee and Starbucks the
once a month and basically cover it and
it provides you the the ongoing support
that you need whatever that is yeah
that's cool that's cool
now where do you see this going in the
next couple of years increasing the
amount of corporate clients that come on
board as well as individual consumers
and what other technologies are you
aiming to manifest and how are you using
all of the crazy biomarker information
that we're learning all this kind of
stuff yeah so first of all you know we
well we have a lot of people coming to
the consumer offering it's it's
essentially not where we're focusing our
efforts we're spending more time when
working in the health plan okay sure
self-insured employers environment so
we're kind of more on the enterprise
side we sing great opportunities with
pharmaceutical companies on digital
therapeutics these are components of the
platform that would go through a FDA
clearance and generally speaking this is
giant opportunity so there's a lot to do
there there's a big market big problems
to solve and technology would be the one
to solve the pre-condition is that you
can engage people and deliver the
outcomes which we can worthy so going I
think that you know the data that is
building in our systems allows us to
start kind of creating machine learning
and
and interfaces that would allow us to
you can further improve the care and you
know we have I do see a lot of
opportunities to integrate AI I do see a
lot of opportunities to integrate
sensors that matter for your emotional
health we're already doing it with heart
rate variability which is a clinical
measurement of stress sleep is very
important if you're sleep-deprived your
entire emotional regulation mechanism is
just not there yes so we do say
opportunities with stress sleep and
other sensors and I think that our point
of view about the adoption of all these
crazy sensors we'd like to see the
market maturing and essentially the
sensors that would become relevant in
our point of view would ultimately be
commercialized by the hardware companies
or another hardware company we
understand software and we want to
interact with hardware that is
widespread yeah okay cool and then the
hardware that you interact with is
thinking about like the neuro tech
hardware's and the and the biotech
hardware so yeah how how would you then
dial down I mean integrating with that
is very interesting but then also trying
to integrate with that and how you're
working with the health plans that this
is a whole new beast so you have to you
know there's a tendency to kind of
innovate the next and kind of stretch
innovation you have to realize that the
mechanisms by which people getting the
care today in the healthcare system or
mechanisms and environments that are
kind of there they realize that
innovation is important but there's a
pace of innovation that can that they
can digest this is a large complex
healthcare system and and you have to
make sure that you innovate in a pace
that you can commercialize you
and we've had the moments where we kind
of had so many cool things that we did
we would say this is too innovative we
should wait with that it just did your
system is not ready yet for that so I
like how you said innovate at a rate
that can be digested most people don't
think about that it's that's that's a
good point as well is yeah get to the
market as the market is getting ready
for the services and there's a lot of
red tape and bureaucracy to go through
with with health plans so I I also I'm
very grateful that you're pursuing that
route is this a tough route to pursue
and thank you for everything that you're
doing this is a this is a really
important project you guys everyone
check out half of five links in the bio
check them out over what a pleasure
yes likewise thank you pleasure pleasure
being here thank you for talking to us
on the show everyone thanks for tuning
in like I said check out the rest of
your thoughts in the comments we'd love
to hear from you embark on this go and
manifest the future build the future
build your destiny into the world thanks
everyone and we'll see you soon